we got a brand-new week and it is time
again to talk to you about the latest
games in new releases but how are you
gonna play all these games
I mean really dead that guy who shot
like six times murdered soul suspect
comes to old gen current gen and PC
solve your own murder with supernatural
sleuthing drop dead Jun Feng this week
offers us the latest version of Capcom
classic fighter including five new
characters and six new stages
improvements include letting you use
both of your ultra combos in one round
and a better training room to perfect
your Hadouken start team battling June
second call of duty gets a new DLC this
week with invasion coming to xbox one
and 360 so you can enjoy classic combat
through the festive streets of a Mexican
towns celebrating Dia de los Muertos
espero que los mapas no Sun pequeno Day
of the Dead starts june trace after a
lot of beta time wildstar comes out on
pc this week the massive multiplayer
online science-fiction role-playing game
looks like nothing but weird explosive
fun take on aliens and robots and alien
robots with your friends and dance like
nobody's watching looking good become
alienated june third let's get serious
for a second to talk about war thunder
which is finally making its way to ps4
this week with gorgeous details hundreds
of planes and a trailer that the movie
Pearl Harbor wishes it was it's gonna be
a great game for ps4 owners get in the
cockpit june third i also got to mention
Tomodachi life because it's like the
sims on acid Tamagotchi Tamagotchi
Tamagotchi this unbelievably weird world
comes to life with me characters you
create and then they get into some
strange situations that you observe and
feel awkward about afterwards my body is
ready in five hundred years this video
game might represent our culture at the
time one can only hope
and finally a thousand and one spikes
comes to dash your hopes of feeling same
this week the 2d action platformer pits
you against the deadly temple ruins
avoiding deadly traps and triggers and
yeah you guessed it spikes for further
details visit gamespot's new releases
page release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week
you